we have done plenty of stories pat about
small numbers of people owning
ridiculous portions of the world's
wealth last year it was reported that
there were eight men who owned what was
equal to the wealth of about half the
world's population last year it was
reported that six men owned an amount of
wealth equivalent to the poorest half of
the world's population as of this month
five men owned almost as much wealth as
half the world's population this is a
story about worsening inequality this is
a story about a situation a status quo
that is really bad for the economy and
this is all based on a new Oxfam study
of data from all of 2016 the poorest 50
percent of the world's population owns
about four hundred and ten billion
dollars in total wealth and as of June
8th of this year
five men collectively owned more than
400 billion dollars in wealth roughly
the same on average each of those men
owns as much wealth as 750 million
people the American economic system and
the wealth inequality that it produces
are a major part of the problem in 2016
alone the richest 1% of Americans
shifted nearly 4 trillion dollars in
wealth away from the rest of the country
half of that wealth came from the
poorest 90 percent of the United States
and when we hear from the right Pat and
the supply siders and the voodoo
economics supporters whatever you want
to call them they say we're against
redistribution of wealth
we don't want wealth there because it
redistributes from the rich to the poor
we don't want mandates for health
insurance because it redistributes
subsidies from the rich to the poor what
we are seeing in terms of our
fundamental economic system and the
stock market as we've talked about with
a common economist Richard wolf is
redistribution of wealth but the
opposite way from the poor to the rich
and the one-percenters generally don't
seem to have a problem with that
yeah and they seem to get a pass on it
too because of course with all that
money you can do a lot
good so you have the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation or have these great
charitable works that they do some
people will hear what I say and they'll
say well baby this is good news America
is the best we've got the best rich
people truly tremendous rich people in
our country this is not a good thing as
Pat is pointing out but forget about it
being bad morally that you know that's
very subjective it's bad economically
and it's bad for everyone you need for
business to function you want the
largest number of people possible able
to afford the goods and services
produced by those businesses when you
see this redistribution of wealth to the
top one percent or higher you end up
with fewer people able to afford to go
out and buy stuff not to mention that it
is widely known that at a purely
technical level inequality leads to more
criminality and from an economic
standpoint more criminality is not good
for the economy when you have to invest
money in enforcing the law because more
people are committing crimes that's also
not a good thing economic and the irony
here is that it's perhaps in the best
interest of the rich to support social
programs and some sort of progressive
tax rate because if there's inequality
to an extent that it creates some sort
of unrest that's not going to be very
good for them I mean you have to support
things maybe even the future like a
universal basic income it's obvious and
oh and being exposed to the wealth
inequality that exists is only going to
exacerbate what Pat is talking about so
we've got wealth inequality continuing
to grow in the US we've got American
children now with a lower average
quality of life compared to their
parents according to a 20-17
April 2017 study from Harvard Stanford
and Berkeley and the healthy diet divide
in the United States is growing too the
diets of people with higher incomes are
getting better
while people at the bottom are less and
less able to afford healthy food based
on a recent study that uses the American
Heart Association's guidelines to define
healthy food there are those who will
hear all of this and say David we live
in a meritocracy people deserve the
money that they have and people have the
money that they deserve because of what
they produce for society that's not true
either
the truth is that a great deal of those
the 1% are involved with finance the
financial services industry and they are
producing nothing and I'm not saying
that to be insulting that I'm not saying
these are bad people I have many friends
in that industry economic study after
economic study has determined that the
fruits of the financial industry in
terms of the benefits to the economy at
large are almost nothing in terms of
what they are providing to the economy
they are by and large enriching the
people in the industry at the expense of
those who are disadvantaged by this
upward redistribution of wealth yeah I
mean the idea that the richest of the
rich deserve everything that they have
because they're all self-made and they
earned it right isn't necessarily true
when you have families like the Waltons
who just inherited their wealth to the
Waltons own half 40% 40 to 50 40 percent
of what the American economy is the
poorest half of the American economy and
then you've got these five men who own
the same amount of wealth as the poorest
50 percent of the entire world and many
of the billionaires that we sometimes
consider to be sort of like innovators
our business men like you know Bill
Gates and Mark Zuckerberg and Jeff Bezos
they get credit for creating technology
that would have been created anyway or
were created partially through our tax
dollars through corporate subsidies
through universities etc and this is not
to take away from their success in any
way but the idea that they are self-made
completely independently of the Commons
and have shared resources and of
taxpayer money you're living in a
fantasy world if that's what you believe
so we need reform in a number of ways we
need tax fairness we need to to really
go after these attempts from
particularly Republicans in the House
and Senate to gut regulations like
dodd-frank which will further empower
Wall Street we need more oversight for
financial markets in general probably a
stronger Volcker rule as well enlarging
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
and if the private market is failing to
provide jobs and growth and the job
market is suffering why wouldn't the
government apply monetary
and fiscal policies that would help to
bolster employment and we could go on
and I've talked about it for a while
where are Democrats on a lot of these
issues we hear almost nothing from too
many Democrats the pathetic corporate
Democrats who are not out there every
day talking about we've got to get
health care for everybody people need to
stop making employment decisions based
on losing health care for example I
could go on and on I don't want to I
don't want to go off on a tangent Pat
but Democrats have got to get it
together and and part of this is
Democrats were elected by the same
status quo that Republicans were elected
yet another part of this too with some
of the richest of the rich support
Democrats you have people like Michael
Bloomberg or Warren Buffett who were
somewhat liberal that's good and and
it's a it's good to point that out
because we need to understand that it's
not just Republicans are the rich and
and the rich are for Republicans but
also that on many issues including that
those of how politics are financed we've
got to be criticizing Democrats as much
as we're criticizing Republicans or
almost as much if that's what they
deserve and by and large it is talked
about this with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash reddit today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30 day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly
for calm /t DPS